government tries to accomplish too much
it taxes too much come on let's balance
the federal budget do it I'll sign it I
would say this is genuinely smaller
government this isn't just smaller
social and welfare program expenditure
most Republicans are conservative
fiscally and so are libertarians we're
not interested in taking your money and
giving it to welfare recipients and
we're certainly not interested in giving
your money to corporations either if you
will look at the philosophy of a
conservative libertarian I mean
Republican that is what a libertarian is
if you want the Republican Party to get
better and be more like the party of
William F Buckley you do that by voting
libertarian and sitting them that
message in particular when you're going
up against somebody like from who's all
of a sudden we've got the Republican
nominee calling for tariffs a lot of a
constitutional conservative and I think
that the libertarian values that I've
been hearing especially from some of the
candidates here match mine but Donald
Trump the presumptive nominee of the GOP
it de-stresses me very much we had
several good candidates two of which I
were interested I was interested in both
of which are gone and I needed to find
an alternative it works with my values
you got disappointed because someone
didn't adhere to a certain principles
that you are adhering to I hope that you
will give the concepts and virtues of
Liberty a deeper look and understand
it's better for you for your family and
for everyone else on the planet and
welcome aboard to our family at the end
of the day Republicans always talk about
small government they would talk about
limited government about individual
liberty
and what candidate would be speak more
to individual liberty than the
Libertarian Party Gannett surely not
Trump so in that case if you really care
about individual liberty if you really
care about the values of Republican say
then libertarians make sense is the only
option in 2016 you have somebody who
will likely be on the ballot in all 50
states that was a former Republican
governor you may not agree with
everything he says but he's likely going
to be the best you're going to get and
as unfortunate as it may be to be in the
situation you may need to consider
voting for the lesser of three evils
Ronald Reagan said if you're 80% my
friend you're not 20% my enemy we have
an issue right now our country's in
crisis our state is in crisis we need to
find commonality when the house is
burning down you don't argue about the
color of the flowers in the front yard
you know you find your place on the hose
let's set some of those social issues
aside temporarily so I would say to
conservatives that I will defend their
religious freedom I will never make them
bake the cake and I will defend our
country come to Libertarian Party
because we have principles that that if
you perceive the fundamental truth of
them that you will then perceive how
they apply to everything whether it's
just an ID or economics or of the
government if you actually believe in
small government if you believe that the
government that governs best is the
government that governs least if you
want lower taxes if you want the
government to in effect cut spending not
just pretend to cut spending ten years
from now or 20 years from now or make up
numbers about smaller increases but
actually cut back the federal
government's involvement in your life if
you want those sort of things that
conservatives going back to Goldwater
actually stood for that the Republican
Party just doesn't stand for anymore the
Libertarian Party is your political home